summarizing what we have done so far a
tiny fraction of our C's is protected
according to the best standards of
international practice a small fraction
is protected from the most damaging of
fishing activities but most marine
protected areas don't qualify against
international criteria for management
and protection which means that we
instead of having exceeded the UN target
of 10% protection we are way behind that
curve as yet so what can we do well
actually it's it's not that hard to fix
things a simple policy shift could
rescue the network and what we need to
do is to afford protection to whole
ecosystems and sites rather than
focusing on bits of them and on very low
levels of protection we should properly
resource that management and ensure that
there's sufficient surveillance and
enforcement and instead of setting
targets for nature to fulfill like
staying in the same state let's give
nature the protection that it needs and
let it dictate what come back is
possible and by doing that we will have
an internationally successful network of
marine protected areas that will be at
the forefront of conservation practice
not just in Europe but in the whole
world so instead of being an
embarrassment our national network and
breen protected areas could be something
to be absolutely proud of so this point
I want to hand over to Hugo tank on from
surface against sewage
[Applause]
Thank You Callan and Thank You Lois for
inviting surface against sewage to be
part of this amazing challenge i'm hugo
take home I run the charity surface
against sewage over the past 30 years
the time that Lewis has been swimming
the oceans the charity has grown from a
single issue pressure group into one of
the UK's best-known marine conservation
charities representing anyone and
everyone who loves the ocean not just
surfers the charity is perhaps one of
the most authentic voices of the sea due
to the visceral and passionate
connection our community has with the
oceans and the beaches around the UK so
closes this connection with the ocean
that I often hear them described as the
canary in the coal mine of the issues we
work on they are marine indicator
species themselves they're people who
live and breathe the ocean and they have
a regular if not daily interaction with
water just like Louis and plastic
pollution is currently our priority
focus plastics and extraordinary
material flexible colorful light
abundant and almost indestructible
yes had an impact on every industry and
revolutionized the very way that we live
is helped us explore the farthest
reaches of the planet from the deepest
ocean trenches to the highest mountain
ranges and even beyond our atmosphere
through space travel but plastics also
an extraordinary pollutant flexible
colorful light abundant and almost
indestructible the very properties that
make it so useful also make it so
problematic when it escapes into the
environment the ocean can often be the
final destination for plastic waste
carried by wind streams rivers currents
into oceanic whirlpools of plastic
indeed it seems increasingly unlikely
that a pristine plastic free environment
today truly exists on any part of planet
ocean as Jacque Cousteau said water and
air the two essential fluids on which
all
life depends have become global garbage
cans
however plastic is also becoming an
extraordinary unifier the very
properties which make it so useful and
so problematic its durability
it's like weigh its colorfulness make it
the pollutant that everyone can see
understand and react to in their
everyday lives the millions of tons of
plastic that enter our oceans annually
are the same as the millions of tons of
plastic the people interact with every
day in our shops in our restaurants in
our homes and in our offices the tide
line on most beaches usually has the
same plastic brand profile as the high
street immediately recognizable to
anyone taking part in a beach clean this
jetsam is a warning sign of a failing
linear economy excessive packaging
unnecessary plastics poor resource
management and fragmented recycling
systems scenes of beaches cities and
wilderness choked with plastic have also
generated a tidal wave of community
action again to quote Jacques Cousteau
to see the great unifier is man's only
hope now as never before the old phrase
has a literal meaning we are all in the
same boat surface against which
collaborates with over 75,000 community
beach clean volunteers annually now the
biggest community of beach cleaners in
the UK and one of the biggest in the
world and will continue to tackle
plastic pollution at the frontline where
land and sea converge interlocked bias
weight of plastic but we know we can't
simply pick our way out of the problem
whilst we're committed to removing and
recycling as much plastic as we can from
our beaches every piece removed a
victory in its own right we also now
need to focus
upstream efforts in the war on avoidable
plastics our army of beach cleaners is
being augmented on a new front in our
villages in our towns and in our cities
through our plastic free communities
campaign and plastic free communities is
a movement designed to unite and empower
people to reduce their collective
plastic footprint it's the only
step-by-step community framework
inspired by the fair trade movement
uniting individual schools business and
community groups local government and
national government to tackle avoidable
single-use paths
in the process we're also seeing local
economic and community regeneration the
campaign's been a huge success since its
launch just 11 months ago over 350
communities signed up to the process
representing 25 million people working
towards this plastic free status both
nationally and internationally
afterall the majority of the plastic
pollution that we're finding on our
coastline is avoidable or recyclable
straws stirrers plastic bottles plastic
bags disposable lighters and much more
these all have solutions upstream to
preserve prevent their presence on our
beaches this is what plastic free
communities is designed to do the time
for action is now and it's up to us all
not to kick the plastic bottle down the
street we can all join a beach clean or
be part of a plastic free community
industry must use plastic free policies
to drive market advantage and respond to
the global growing community that
demands it a consumer revolt is is under
way against unnecessary plastics and I
urge us all to take action we'll be
organizing beach cleans as part of the
long swim with speedo and with Luis and
we'll be doing those from tomorrow in
Mara Sian I'm down in Cornwall at 10:00
a.m. and I'd like to thank Lewis and
speedo and all of the the participants
for the opportunity to work together on
this huge issue that threatens all of
our oceans and all of our marine
protected areas thank you
[Applause]
good thank you very very much
we now open up the floor to any
questions great so we went down to the
University of Portsmouth yesterday and
met a man called Professor Tipton who is
and he put me through some tests a
normal male of my size will be consuming
about 2,500 a day if I assume for about
two hours a day I'll be up to 5,000
calories and if I do which are what I'm
hoping towards the end of the swim I'm
hoping to do about three hours on and
then in the evening another three hours
I'd be close to 10,000 calories a day so
I'll spend a lot of day eating and
swimming
no not yet hi Emily
I Lois um can you just tell me how
different this is going to be from the
swims you've done before and in what
ways yes
great so for the last couple of years
I've been swimming in the Arctic and the
Antarctic and these are Short's rooms
obviously because the water is so
extremely cold and these are swims for
about a kilometer and I'm in the water
for up to 23 minutes and they require me
to sprint as fast as I can to be able to
survive in the water be under no
illusion that when you dive into the
Arctic or the Antarctic you are on the
edge of death and also there are serious
predators in the water I just come back
from doing that swim in South Georgia
where you have enormous great elephant
seals everywhere you have leopard seals
you have fur seals up in the Arctic you
got polar bears you got walruses it is
it is a very very dangerous swim this
swim on the other hand is the longest
swim which I will ever have attempted
and it requires a completely different
mindset I was just saying to a friend
last night I was explaining the Admiral
Stockdale principle you may have heard
of it Admiral Stockdale was the
highest-ranking American aviator shot
down in Vietnam he spent eight years in
a prison of war camp and he said that
there was a paradox about those people
who survives he said on the one hand
those people who survived they believed
that one day they would be free but the
paradox was that they had no optimism no
hope because those people who had hope
said that's okay come Christmas and will
be freed and Christmas came and they
weren't freed ok come Christmas come
East er May hopefully we'll be freed and
Easter came and they weren't freed what
about Thanksgiving and so they were
constantly believing and hoping that
there'd be freedom they weren't and it
dashed all their hopes and those were
the people who didn't survive so the
people who survives
had that raw reality they believed that
one day there would be free but they
didn't have any hope and there's a
paradox I mean the world is divided
between pioneers and some pioneers and
followers you're either a pioneer or
you're a follower
nobody has ever attempted to swim
anywhere close to this distance before
and so there's nobody I can ask for
advice from and on the one hand I I know
that I will get to Dover I know that I
will see the White Cliffs of Dover but
the paradox is I just don't know how I
you know and it's easy enough to say
okay Louis you know you break this swim
down into manageable chunks and you just
swim each day but the human mind just
doesn't work like that I'm worried about
tomorrow I'm worried about next week and
actually I'm also worried about next
month swimming Mike Tyson always used to
say everybody has got a plan until they
get punched in the face and it's it's so
true you know everybody is saying to me
well Louis you just swim ten kilometres
a day and you just keep on going and
keep on going until you swim into your
first bloom of jellyfish until the boat
has a problem until you've got problems
with the crew and they're saying Louis
you sure you can do this and it's about
holding all this stuff together with one
common vision and that is we are going
to Dover and we're going to Dover
because we've got a reason to get to
Dover it is I don't use this word likely
but it is shocking that a country which
portrays itself as an ocean leader has
only protected fully protected just
seven square kilometres out of 750,000
square kilometres and is also it is
deeply disturbing that the single most
important part of British soil which is
South Georgia and the South Sandwich
Islands the single most important from a
biodiversity point of view single most
important area less than two percent of
it is fully protected we can do better
and we must do better
yes short answer yes you can get your
body right but ultimately it's gonna be
the heart that's gonna get me to Dover
it's it's gonna be an enormous physical
journey and it's gonna be an enormous
mental journey and as I said I don't
know how I'm gonna do it I hope to be
here 50 days from now explaining how I
did it just conservation aspects I know
you mentioned government involvement in
this so have you and your team had any
involvement with sort of consulting on
any new policies I mean particularly
with brexit on the horizons of any new
fisheries or marine policies in that
area so let me quickly talk about brexit
I'm the UN ambassador for the oceans I
need to be neutral I need to be
independent I need to be non-aligned I'm
I I know that there are it is a very
divisive issue here in the United
Kingdom and I prefer not to speak about
about brexit what what I will say is
that when it comes to the oceans I would
have been arguing that we needed to be
properly protecting our oceans where the
brexit was happening or it wasn't
happening with respect to dealing with
the government I've had regular meetings
with Michael Gove to talk about about
what we need to do he was scheduled to
be here today but unfortunately it was a
very very busy day
hello I counted the cost 300 350
kilometres yes yes I hope so but just
bearing in mind there are three big bays
in which we have to cross so the mounts
pay over here the bay in front of
Plymouth and then obviously Lyme Bay
over here and across these Bay's we will
be very very far out at sea and so these
bays will take a few days to cross so
I'll be swimming for 3-4 hours GPS in
the points coming back to harbor then
later on in the evening to get the
second tide going out there and coming
back so along those sections it's not
really possible for to interact with the
public but when we pass when we get to
towards the Isle of Wight when we get to
Bournemouth then I'll be hugging the
coast and as far as I'm concerned I
would absolutely love members of the
public to come and swim with me I want
this to be a people swim yep
yes I don't know if you saw the sky news
documentary last night's which there's a
Royal Navy captain who has been advising
us on this and it's especially the
headlands where you've got the fast
tides moving and especially around here
anvil points and the these heavens over
here as you approach the Isle of Wight
which are which are treacherous so the
the tides move through there very very
quickly in fact you have whirlpools
there you have eddies when you have the
winds moving in one direction and the
tide moving in the other direction you
can have absolutely treacherous seas so
that section is an area which I'm very
worried about the other section I'm
worried about is that apparently from
Weymouth all the way through to Plymouth
it is now because of the warm water
completely full with jellyfish yep and
there's no easy way of navigating your
way through jellyfish especially if
you're swimming at night
I've Tim is laughing because Tim was
with me when I swam down the Thames and
late one night he had to take me to
Oxford Hospital he had to take me to
another hospital just ingesting
pollution I've only ever been sick on
two swims both of them or three swims
and all three of them were swimming in
rivers I think I'm going to be a case
swimming out at sea but but who knows
yep I can't I don't want to speak on
behalf of Michael you know I'm sure
you've listened to him speak he when it
comes to the oceans he is you know he is
his father and his grandfather were both
involved in the oceans he speaks very
very passionately about what he feels we
need to do with the oceans all I would
say is this the United Kingdom has the
opportunity now to be a world leader in
ocean conservation I would urge him to
grab this opportunity with both hands
[Applause]
Thomas and the UN Ambassador I I need to
be diplomatic about this but at this but
at the same time we also need to be
realists you know I mean I I've been
swimming as I say for 30 years and it's
a very very small time in ecological
times and and the changes have been
absolutely dramatic I've explained what
I saw in the Arctic ten years ago I was
swimming across the Maldives across the
coral reefs there and it's just it was
so wonderful to swim across those coral
reefs you look underneath you and it's
like swimming onto the set of Nemo
beautiful tropical fish that colors the
vibrancy the sharks that the turtles
everything I went back there last year
and it was like swimming over rubble the
water temperatures risen just a bit and
everything has died you go down to
Antarctica go down to a place like
deception island and swim across
deception island underneath your all
these whale bones whale bones upon whale
bones upon whale bones and when the
great whalers came in there and
literally destroyed that place and so
we've seen the great big industrial
fishing fleets first they came for the
seals and then they came for the whales
and now they're coming for the Antarctic
toothfish and even coming for the
tiniest life on earth crow on which
every single thing in the southern ocean
survives and you just see this and you
realize it that unless we take action
right now that the future for our oceans
is isn't is not a bright one and and and
I feel that the United Kingdom is
perfectly placed as a maritime nation as
a g7 nation as the currently running the
presidency of chögyam to lead the world
on these issues and I would really
encourage them to the single most
important thing now for the new Foreign
Secretary is properly protecting the
South Sandwich Islands this has gone on
far too long it's gone on far too long
you know some of the best scientific
advice was reduced to barrister on
and scientists from many different
universities explained to him exactly
why this place needs protecting South
Georgia South Sandwich Islands are like
the Serengeti of the southern ocean
there's a reason why blue planets you
know film so much down there because
this place is so very very important
and that's I would I would argue one of
the most important things now on his
agenda as he now takes office it's very
very interesting because thank you Paul
because nobody's ever done a swim like
this before you you just don't know
quite how much training you should do
you know using a steak analogy should
you go in there rare medium rare medium
medium well done well done I think that
I what we decided was I should go in
there medium rare and the reason for
that is because we've got fifty days of
swimming ahead of me and I wanted to
arrive on the start line as relaxed and
not mentally tired so I've been swimming
around about seven kilometres a day I
started my training down in the Falkland
Islands and I've spent the last six
months training off the Cape of Good
Hope in rough cold seas and so I feel
ready but I'm going to get fitter and
fitter as this event carries on
good ladies and gentlemen I want to
thank you all very very much for coming
here today and a huge thank you to FX TM
and to speedo for your very very
generous help with this expedition I
wouldn't be able to do it without you
and I want to thank you very very much
thank you
[Applause]